okay so we had a really great interview
scheduled for you for today and then
something that happens every few months
happened which is because of a
last-minute shake up that interview had
to be rescheduled and that's unfortunate
but the good and bad news of it is that
I'm going to take just a few phone calls
at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 if you dislike
phone calls don't worry because this
will be a very short phone call segment
if you are one of the people who last
night on my live stream on YouTube the
dozens of people who couldn't get on but
wanted to here's another opportunity
okay so let's see what's on people's
minds at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 we'll start
with our caller from the 4-1 to area
code caller from 4:1 - who's this where
you calling from
yes it is hi I'm Zach I'm from the
Pittsburgh suburbs hey Zack so I
recently became a voting age last year
and while I did vote in the midterms I
was wondering is there any way I could
become more politically active yes so in
between elections you should be talking
to people about how important it is that
they vote so at a micro level like if if
education is really important to you
become an activist for education reform
if the environment is really important
to you get involved in climate related
activism but half the country doesn't
vote Zack so the most impactful thing
that you can do is just get more people
to vote because as bill scher and I
spoke about on the program yesterday
when half the country doesn't vote the
biggest opportunity to effect change is
to find people who already agree with
you and just get them to vote and you
can have a major impact that way alright
thanks for calling it appreciate it
great to hear from new young voters
especially especially in Pennsylvania
which is an important state politically
let's go as are all states of course